est ce que la religion originale d ea
nous est encore pratiqué ou et bienvenue
à part à l'automne si ces milices au
moulin depuis cette semaine je vais
répondre à la question de gabriel en
mettant je pense des nouveaux concepts
dans votre tête
alors ce qui est très important c'est de
savoir que la religion chez les i nous
est arrivé avec l'arrivée des européens
parce que la religion ça veut dire
quelque chose qui est enchâssé dans un
dogue une bible des commandements
c'était pas la manière de pratiquer la
spiritualité qu'on avait autrefois la
spiritualité est beaucoup plus souple à
s'adapter aux territoires aux réalités
aux animaux qu'on chasse aux expériences
qu'on a vécu sur un territoire donné et
bien sûr c'est cette spiritualité l'a
aussi s'entremêlaient avec les autres
spiritualité donc souvent on allait
comparer on allait changer des
cérémonies deschamps mais bien sûr
c'était pas une religion donc c'était
très vivant et très flexible sa éviter
justement de faire des guerres de
religion parce qu'on peut s'entendre sur
le fait que chacun avait une manière
différente de croix ou de pratiquer le
territoire alors ce qui est arrivé par
exemple avec l'arrivée des européens
on a amené des nouveaux donne une
nouvelle manière de faire est une des
raisons pourquoi les i nous ont adoptés
aussi facilement la religion catholique
c'est qu'elles s'adaptent est beaucoup à
notre croyance du grand esprit la
pratique sur le territoire parce qu'on
pouvait partir nous autres sur notre
territoire avec la capacité de prier
comme on chantait la capacité de
communiquer mon manger et cette croyance
que le grand esprit était partout et de
surveiller la seule chose qui a été
rajouté
c'était l'enfer parce que ça on en avait
pas d'ailleurs s'arrêter bien que nous
on parle pas on n'aurait pas su on
serait jamais allé là bas mais avec les
années oui la spiritualité des premières
nations a quand même traversé l'histoire
et la religion catholique en
s'entremêlent aujourd'hui je partage son
expérience de qu'on fait la fête de
sainte anne de beaupré justement une
défaite est allé très importante chez
les i nous on va aller à la rivière on
va manger du saumon en faire la prière
la messe en plein air et soit ça va être
aussi fêté à sainte anne de beaupré
justement à québec
c'est un des plus gros pèlerinage qu'il
faut se voir au québec mais pourquoi
s'étendent mais parce que ça s'adapter à
l'idée qu'on avait du respect de la
grand-mère donc la grand maman de jésus
c'est une fête on va célébrer pour plus
de façon beaucoup plus important mais
avec le temps avec aussi ce qu'il
arrivait de négatif avec la religion
c'est à dire les pensionnats avec
l'impact que ces pensionnats et que
certains des curés des religieuses ont
eu sur les jeunes de la génération des
parents
il ya eu un rejet complet du
catholicisme pour une ré adoption des
savoirs et des pratiques traditionnelles
beaucoup plus proche de nous et il ya eu
un courantes pendant des années sans les
années 70 où certaines nations de
l'ouest ont donné des savoirs des chants
des pratiques spirituelles à toutes les
nations pour pouvoir justement combler
le vide qui a été fait par la
colonisation
donc on voit une montée de la pratique
du souhaite loge sous la forme d'une
hippie les danses aussi donc des fois ça
peut même amener des contrastes assez
brutale en des personnes sur très
croyante
au niveau des religions catholique et
qu'un kg et très pratiquant au niveau
des spiritualités des profanations
cependant aujourd'hui on vit dans une
modernité qui nous permet aussi de faire
des choix un peu partout dans toutes les
formes de religion et ou de spiritualité
donc oui les croyances des premières des
premières nations les croyances des
inouk a traversé l'histoire s'est adapté
à ce qui s'est passé dans l'histoire est
d'ailleurs la religion n'était pas une
première forme d'appropriation culturel
où on sait que la religion catholique
approprié certaines des célébrations
païennes pour pouvoir en faire les leurs
bien nous en a pris certaines des
célébrations catholique et on en a fait
quelque chose qui ressemblait beaucoup
plus à celles de nos nations
donc j'espère avoir pu répondre
intégration se comprendrait que c'est
une question énorme
n'hésitez pas à vous informer justement
sur les pratiques spirituelles qui sont
autour de vous et à vous y intéresser et
c'était pas nous envoyer des questions
et à partager cette vidéo je souhaite
une belle semaine